to Chairman Fred Hampton how blessed we
are that we lived in a lifetime where he
existed him Huey P Newton Bobby seal a
black panther party they showed me how
to love myself and with that love they
overflowed it to the black community and
to other communities
and they showed us that the power of
Union
power of unity that when they played
divide and conquer we say unite and
Ascend I Look to everyone every single
one of you you've got work to do you
understand
and I'm going to get back to work
Tuesday morning
because tonight I'm going up
we're going up you know what I mean
we're enjoying ourselves tonight because
we celebrate we've got to celebrate life
man we're breathing we're walking it's
incredible it's incredible
like it's incredible my mom met my dad
they had sex it's amazing like you're
saying I'm here and I appreciate every
single person in the room appreciate
everyone watching at home you know love
peace love and onwards we go again